my name is Karen morning with la talk
radio's film courage we're here with mr.
David H Lawrence the 17th plays one of
the villains on heroes one of the one of
the many one of the many yeah curious um
tell us about the struggle I'm really I
gotta tell you I can't see your eyes and
it's driving me crazy okay it's like
she's eating up an atom Madame Han she's
very mysterious you know she's got the
things like cave so about this acting
thing all right ladies what are the
struggles you know it just so it's like
it's like Lady Gaga hear something so
it's better much better now we can yes I
totally but there's anything I never
connect I wise no I'm just like whatevs
I don't care you know it's really funny
because I've only been my very first
booking network television wise was
heroes very first one and it was only
supposed to be for one episode it's
turned out to be 13 now thank you very
much Tim appreciate it but the problems
I think are many times problems that
actors set up for themselves you know I
hear people say all the time oh there's
no parts for older actors there are no
parts for actors that aren't pretty and
there are no parts for actors don't have
great hair or you name the state of
affairs of a person usually it's older
women that complain about this and I
think to myself you know I made the
decision to come out to Los Angeles to
be an on-camera actor when I was 45
which is well past most people's Prime's
I had a pretty good running radio for 30
years or so and I thought you know maybe
this goofy face will work on camera I
don't know I you know it always wanted
to be an on-camera actor and so I just
decided to move from Washington DC to
Los Angeles to become an actor and I
like anything else I just treated it
like a business I treated it like any
sort of a project that needed to be
researched and skilled and marketed and
then executed and you know i'm not i
don't know whether I'm I don't think I'm
lucky I just think that I'm prepared and
it's kind of nice that you know other
people think the same thing too because
you've got a lot of people that are
walking through Hollywood think they're
really good and maybe they're not so
good but but I think being prepared and
being a team player and being
enthusiastic and putting in your dues
ahead of time it was a great book that
Malcolm Gladwell just put out called the
outliers and it talks about talked about
why people are world class and you know
my run in computers and in radio
definitely fall into the category of
10,000 hours of practice and so on and i
was born in September so I got that
advantage of being larger than the other
kids but I think that if you're
persistent and if you really i mean
really persistent not persistent kind of
but persistent nicely persistent
volunteerism is a big part of it you
know being willing to be a part of a
film where you make no money but you
your currency there is his experience
you know learning to make your mistakes
and student films and independent films
and then learning from that and so on
but the the struggle the most actors
have is with confidence and another
problem and with resources a lot of
actors just really don't have the money
to put into their careers and I was
fortunate in that area as well and and
then on top of it being ready to say yes
to the opportunities that present
themselves certainly heroes and then
lost and then CSI the unit all the other
shows that have been on
were examples of hey go audition for
this get the job and being ready to get
the job you know so that answer your
question thank you very much and I have
the glasses back on of course because
very bright under the lights are the
shirt explain it's my very cool from
target shirt turn it down so
you